thank you
Brothers in Arms Gianluca viali
embracing Roberto Mancini his former
teammate and friend for over 40 years
after watching Italy win the Euros in
2021
Mancini the head coach had hired the Ali
as the team's delegation Chief a role he
continued in until last month before
stepping away to focus on his health
viali was originally diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer in 2017 but given the
all clear a year later only for it to
return a few months after Italy's
Triumph at Wembley Stadium he died on
Friday leaving his wife and two
daughters
it's a sad day for me I say goodbye to a
friend a colleague a very nice person a
great player may he rest in peace
the Ali's career took off when he signed
for sampdoria in 1984. he scored 85
League goals won the serial title three
Italian cups and the European Cup
winners cup as well
he was soon called up to the national
team and went on to play 59 times for
Italy representing them at two World
Cups Mexico 1986 an Italia 90.
in 1992 we secured a then world record
move to Juventus for 15 million dollars
he won another Italian title the UEFA
Cup and the prestigious Champions League
Juventus coach massimiliano allegri led
a minute silence at his press conference
on Friday before paying his own tribute
representative he represented a lot
firstly as a player but even more as a
man I think that for the younger players
he was a model to follow therefore we
will all miss him terribly after
Juventus fiali's next move was to the
Premier League when rude hullit brought
him in at Chelsea he ended up replacing
the Dutchman as player manager and
guided the London side to five trophies
and there it is his first goal in a
Chelsea shirt this was somebody who
introduced us to a new era of quality at
the club whose ability to communicate
the link between the players and the
supporters
um was absolutely everything to us
a minute silence will be held across all
Seria matches this weekend in memory of
viali Italy's Football Federation
president said his sporting success was
matched by his extraordinary human
qualities